hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
yesterday I posted a video on the
importance of stacked imbalances in the
order flow and you know stacking
balances is something that I've always
looked at in the order flow for as long
as I've been trading with order flow for
uh well over a decade and what I want to
introduce you today is sort of a more
advanced concept it's the concept of
inverse imbalances and you know when you
look at a footprint chart right you see
buying imbalances you see selling
imbalances generally when you see buying
imbalances the market is going up right
you have aggressive buyers active in the
market and if you have sound imbalances
right you're generally going to come in
on the red candles as the market is
selling off right because you got
aggressive sellers taking control of the
market however there are going to be
times where you have you know a red
candle down with mine imbalances or a
green candle up with selling imbalances
and
you know people are going to say yo how
can this Market be going up
if they're selling the balances or how
can this Market go down if there's
buying imbalances and you know just
really sort of rudimentary it's a case
of supply and demand right when you see
you know for example this red candle
here you see Supply coming into the
market it often leaves its
um footprint no pun intended since we're
doing the footprint charts in the
footprint as
a buying a balance because what you have
coming in is you have Supply coming into
the market right just as you know on a
market that's going up
you you know like on a green candle
right you're going to get that selling
amount so you know you have demand
coming in here people sitting on the bed
to absorb whatever selling is going on
now the e-minis is it's an interesting
Market because it's you know probably
the most widely known Futures Market out
there and it does a very good job of
Distributing volume however other
markets such as
um you know ym the mini Dao or NQ NASDAQ
even mnq
it doesn't have the same type of volume
that you have in
um es okay and in the order flows Trader
software we have a setting in there
specifically to highlight inverse
imbalances and basically what inversion
balance is going to be it's going to be
a buying a balance in a red dog candle
or a
um selling a balance in a green up
candle so you know when you look at the
settings it's right here okay now you
could choose how many levels you want to
look for one okay but again you know if
you're looking at one imbalance in a bar
that could just be a big order going
through I like to look for inverse
imbalances
um at a minimum
cluster of two meaning stacked on top of
each other right these are stacked
inverse volume imbalances so I'm going
to enable this right I'm going to keep
my same imbalance trigger a percent of
400 percent four to one right and I want
to be alerted I want to draw it out
until tested now you can see I have
stacked imbalances turned on but I'll
just turn that off right now so there's
there's no confusion between the Stacked
imbalance and the inverse imbalance now
again you know like I said the
es right the e-minis is you know it's
sort of like the Benchmark if you will
for all Futures contracts in terms of
volume it's it's one of those that
trades healthy volume and again like I
said it's very evenly distributed so
something like an inverse imbalance
while they do appear in the
um e minis right like here's one right
here you don't see too many of them
okay and again not every order flow tool
that we've developed is for every single
market and the inverse and balance tool
if you're trading something like mini
Dao the ym is something that's going to
be pretty useful so let's switch over to
the mini dial here and okay so this is
let's go back to you know sort of the
cash open this was uh yesterday Friday
the 11th here okay and again it's
looking for
inverse imbalances like here's two
inverse imbalances but they're spread
out really what I'm looking for is that
stacked inverse imbalance here's a two
here right it's a little hard to see let
me expand that up you got 14 you got 21
but the next bar
trades right through it right so if I'm
looking for an inverse imbalance
right I want to see the market close
down below it which it did but I also
want to see the next bar
start heading lower right not sort of
open in the middle of the previous bars
range and then start trade back up into
it that's not what I'm looking for what
I'm looking for I'll give you a better
example here but let's find one here
um okay this is a perfect example of one
right here write this 10 versus 0 10
versus zero these are solid imbalances
right in this green up candle next Bar
opens up starts straight you know comes
back doesn't even really test it we
don't even get you know get down to 28
the high of this is 22 so six ticks off
of it and then reverses and starts
running up all you gotta do is you just
sit here you know the high of this bar
you know this bar has this inverse
imbalance right and then finally it
closes here you just drop a buy stop in
here right above the high here you know
maybe a tick higher two ticks higher at
40. let the market take you in goes from
40. it does pull back pulls back to what
30 and even over here pulls back to 28
okay but you know you're long from 40 it
shoots up immediately all the way up to
65 pulls back again like I said down to
30 back up to 75 here it pulls back down
to 28 back up into the 60s
so it's a nice
tool to use for you know potential quick
moves and I'm not saying that oh you got
this little inverse imbalance here it's
going to
be the the low for the rest of the day
session no right I mean you're reading
order flow you're reading what's
happening on a very short-term basis and
if you're trading on a short-term basis
you're
Outlook is is short term right you're
not trading a one minute chart to find
swings that are going to last for three
four hours five hours no you're training
this case is a one minute chart right
you're looking what's going to happen
over the next 10 15 20 minutes not the
next three hours right because people
say well yeah you had the inverse
imbalance and it came over here and it
failed well this happened at 10 59 11
o'clock you're getting in it's almost 11
30. should be out of the trade already
right when people uh sometimes they fail
to grasp that concept of of you know
sort of trading the time frame that
you're trading all right so let's see if
we could find another one here right
here's another one right here see the
market shoot up
eventually came down there's one here
didn't go up on the next bar the next
bar went up a couple ticks and just sort
of pulled back into that rotated around
and would have stopped you out
um
let's look at NQ right
give it a second to come up here
and again you know on the thinner traded
markets you're going to see them more
than on the very liquid markets because
you know when it's a very liquid Market
uh oftentimes it's got a lot of
opportunities to come in and fill that
whereas these thinner markets like NQ
that can move
a lot
um
you're going to find a lot more of them
I'm just going back to the the cash open
time period here just to sort of go
through again this is a one minute chart
you can see it was a nice sell there was
a buy here then it came immediately with
a cell there again you're not
necessarily focused so much on what the
actual numbers are this is 8 10 8 11
before the cash opens you know it's one
against 12 it's one against 12. in in a
very broad General sense you know these
are trap Traders here these are trap
Traders up there
um you know Mark came off again one
minute chart
NASDAQ
here let's see
okay nothing nothing this cash open over
here just then here okay
you can see this came in
right here right the 12 against one four
against 19. and you can see right you
know you know it happened early in the
bar bar opened up here traded down here
these guys got trapped in here now again
you're only talking uh 19 and 12
contracts what is that 31 contracts and
it's not like oh these are trap Traders
because up here is trading a lot of
volume so it's not like you got 31
traders that were trapped down here
that's going to cause this move because
they got to scramble to buy it well they
could scramble it buy it they'll be
Fields right here there's 55 contracts
trade here 70 up here
um so it's not like you know it's a
thousand Traders got stuck down there no
it's just it's only 31 contracts but you
sort of see the the shift in the order
flow
these guys you know really what you're
looking for is you know any sort of sign
of people being caught off sides right
and again I'm not
advocating and saying oh you know as
soon as you become a seller you become a
buyer because it's only 31 contracts
right it's not 350 right this bar traded
1800 contracts right the Delta was 259
so in the grand scheme of things 31 is
nothing okay but it's really sort of
catching the shift in what you're
looking at yeah at this time these
Traders were stuck in the market right
and you can see it again it trades from
you know
uh 15 108 you know or 109 110. all the
way you know next bar when you look at
these bars this is a nice thing if you
trade NASDAQ I don't but I know a lot of
my users uh trade NASDAQ but you know
you get those big moves like that okay I
mean there's a few others on Friday I'm
just I'm just scrunching this like it's
a little easier to see the problem with
NASDAQ is it traded so much volume here
it was a buy but again didn't go higher
see it right here expand it up
right
This Bar
the next bar didn't go higher here did
and just sort of rotated around
this was a cell but again you know do
you really want to be taking a cell into
the lows of the day probably not besides
the next bar didn't even go any lower
right you you want to have this this
inverse imbalance and you want to be
trading lower in the next bar not
sideways to higher in the next bar
okay
uh just you know he was a nice buy here
this was a deeper one right for uh price
levels right right here you see the
market you know from basically 80 83 all
the way up up to uh above 100 and even
higher you as a cell didn't really you
know next bar shot down then sort of
pulled back
it was a buy but it didn't go any higher
it was a nice and it was another Buy
all right
10 against two ten against two next bar
that's going higher but then this bar
here finally breaks out again from you
know 77 all the way up again back above
100. so
don't just think in terms of the normal
buying and balances and selling
imbalances you know we're appearing you
know in
green candles and red candles you got to
start thinking outside the box when it
comes to dealing with imbalances because
if you were just going to ignore this
these two selling imbalances in this
green candle Ah that's nothing you know
coincidence whatever you'd miss this
beautiful 30 40 Point trade right here
right so
again you know when when you see these
inverse imbalances pay attention to them
right our order flows Trader software
we've had this in there for well over
you know a couple years two three years
and again if you're trading a market
like NASDAQ or or mini Dao mnq
you're going to see them on a daily
basis because they do happen often right
I mean markets like gold Etc you know
they're going to appear there so might
as well you know have some software have
a tool that's going to help you identify
them and take advantage of them of when
they occur
because you know that's the whole point
of using order flow right because out of
all the people that trade out there you
know people that look at a footprint
chart it's really you know minuscule you
know a percent maybe two or three
percent if that even everybody else is
looking at bar charts they're not going
to see this happening you know this
change in
flow you know somebody coming in here
with some support of buying who you know
help support this Market as it continues
up so
anyway I hope you guys got something
useful out of this video and I'll see
you guys on the next video bye-bye